can we talk about this yeah you were
always rich but now I think you've
bought three countries or something you
are very very well I owned I inherited a
few countries at Birth okay
uh just and that's just something people
should know I as a child and this is
very unusual in an Irish Catholic Family
but I inherited nine islands in Greece
oh yeah and I've been holding on to them
and then I sold them yeah I you were you
are a very
respect that about you I was actually
thinking this because who says that I
respect you know uh you've earned you're
a big fan of trump but then I found out
that he had some money and I'm I do
respect that
but you've earned your wealth he got it
from his dad and he's also a horrible
person my father gave me nothing so
nothing nothing but here's what all I
wanted was a hug here's what I was gonna
say because there are you know there's a
question of whether there's a question
of whether you know straight people will
go see Bros right there's like this big
question mark question mark hanging over
the movie and I really hope straight
people do go see Bros because it's
really really funny and we need you to
go see it right because we want to make
money at the box office so that people
keep making these movies and you know we
prove to the world that you know this is
a good thing we need more of it that
this is a you know a worthwhile uh
venture to keep making movies about gay
people but instead of a lot of straight
people going Conan we could just have
you by 120 million dollar ticket I'll do
it to go see it I'll do it and that's as
much as we need that is the chicken
noodle yeah exactly and rainforest wood
that's all it would take
um I'll do it thank you no but also you
know let me reassure you first of all um
you claim I have all this money someone
will tell you I've made some terrible
Investments
really really bad Investments right I
bought up uh all the VHS machines about
eight years ago wow because I thought
that was coming back yeah
um I've done some terrible terrible I
had to loan him a lot of money yeah and
I'm his assistant yeah yeah I have but
she has it now because well anyway
she's got all the money yeah and also
you embezzled from me and you're not
even a good embezzler but I'm so stupid
about money that you got away with it I
told you I was in besley yeah and I
didn't know what that word meant
and that's why she's not in prison
because they said she did tell you she
was embezzling I was like well I didn't
know what it meant I thought that meant
you just had warm fuzzy feelings I'm all
embezzling about you
but uh no I I'll tell you uh first of
all Billy in in my opinion and I believe
this passionately you are
funny first before I know anything else
about you you're just funny and in my
experience that is what everyone's
hungry for they're hungry for
um they're they're hungry for a movie or
a television show or a moment or
performance that is funny you're also a
talented actor and I know I have not
seen this film yet but I'm going to go
see this movie and I know that you are
going to uh be very relatable and this
is going to be good and it's going to be
very funny but also uh touching in
moments and I think that that is the
Home Run that's going to be the Home Run
and yes I I think that the word on Bros
uh or your work is going to be this is
good yeah and not it's good for America
it of course it's good for society it's
good for the world but I just think it
being funny is what's going to sustain
you as because that's what sustained you
your whole career that's true you know
you have that ability and you know
that's that's how I met you that's how
all of us met you was because you made
it happen you're you're super talented
and yes thank you thank you yeah no and
it is it's a it's weird to say about my
own movie but I've now watched a lot of
you know early audiences at screenings
react to it it is a really [ __ ] funny
movie like it is a again with the
language it is a straight person swears
that's what we've established didn't
George Carlin say that I think
um
it's so weird what a weird Hill for me
to die on yeah only straight everything
you're like I haven't pissed like yeah
but just like you know this is one thing
I'm not backing down on after 30 years
this takes you down yeah I just think
only straight people should swear I
don't know why I'm mixing
those are the current topical references
that you listen to this podcast to hear
I met Cynthia Nixon that's what I meant
I never said Richard Milhouse but this
is how Cynthia Nixon talks now
why because she's gay I'm leaving Conan
not all lesbians Talk Like Richard Nixon
regardless of what you think
you're tired of that old Trope exactly
you're so tired of that troll Trope that
all lesbians Talk Like Richard Nixon's
Talk Like Richard Dixon and all gay men
[ __ ] like LBJ it's just not sure
it's just not true no matter what
Holderman wants you to think Holderman
or look man let's all get in the car and
go see Thelma and Louise
that's the story for us boys
then we'll get back to the water again
and get that safe cracked
what a strange joke it's what a weird
what a weird run joke yeah what a weird
run
you're like don't worry Billy you're
relatable just like me and my lesbian
sound like Richard Nixon material
so related
uh
you're the I'm the next Jeff foxworld
over here I'm worried I just hurt Bros
people gonna be like I don't want to go
see that Nixon's a lesbian in this movie
and he's he's being raped by a dinosaur
Pat Nixon [ __ ] Sonic the Hedgehog and
Bros that's the first lgbtq rom-com
what's happened to Apatow he's lost his
mind